المزيد من المتابعه والقراءه التحليليه
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول العقيد الركن حاتم
كريم الفلاحي الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
عقيد كريم الفلاحي اهلا بك ما الذي يخبرك
به هذا الاداء للمقاومه الاداء العسكري
الميداني المستمر في الصمود واستهداف جيش
الاحتلال واصابته
بخسائر مع اقتراب انتهاء الشهر الثالث من
هذه
الحرب
نعم تحيه لكم ومشاهدي قناه الجزيره نعم لا
شك بان هذا الاداء القتالي يعطي دلاله
واضحه على انها على ان كتائب القسام
وفصائل المقاومه قد تكيفت مع طبيعه
المعركه وطبيعه هذه الحرب التي تجري في
داخل القطاع في المناطق المبنيه وبالتالي
هم يحاولون الان اظهار اكبر قدر ما يمكن
من الجراه ومن المهاره في استخدام ما
لديهم من اسلحه يعني عندما نرى الجندي او
عندما نرى مقاتل يقوم باخذ العبوه الناسفه
ويضعها اسفل الدبابه ثم يقوم بالانسحاب
الى مكان امن ليراها كيف تنفجر هذه جراه
كبيره جدا لا يمكن ان تتوفر لدى قوات
الاحتلال الصهيوني وبالتالي نحن نتكلم عن
مهاره وعن عن عمليه تكييف للوسائل
والامكانيات المتاحه لان مثل هذه الدبابه
كان يمكن ان يستهدفها بياسين 105 ولكن نرى
بانه استخدم العبوه لانه الوسائل المتيسر
لهم في هذه اللحظه في هذا المكان
ما لديهم من امكانيات هي العبوات الناسفه
بهذه الطريقه كذلك نرى بانه مساله استخدام
الوانات التي بدات تظهر الان بشكل كبير
هاونات 60 ملم التي يصل مداها الى 1690
متر يضاف الى ذلك الهاون 82 الذي يصل مداه
الى اكثر من 83 متر هذه الاسلحه بدات
تستخدم بشكل كبير جدا لان طبيعه المعركه
تتطلب استخدام مثل هذه الاسلحه الخفيفه
لمواجهه تقدم العدو الذي يجري على محاور
متعدده وبالتالي نحن نرى بانه استطاعت
حماس من خلال من خلال هذه المعركه ومن
خلال الامكانيات البسيطه التي تمتلكها من
اسلحه ومعدات ان تتكيف الى حاله من
التعادل الميداني مع قوات العدو التي
تمتلك جاهزيه وقدرات عسكريه كبيره جدا
ولكن هذه القدرات لم توظف بالشكل الصحيح
لذلك نرى بانه مساله الخسائر ترتفع يوم
بعد يوم على كل المستويات البشريه وعلى
مستوى الاليات والمدرعات يضاف الى ذلك بان
الحاله النفسيه التي التي يتمتع بها
المقاتل في كتائب القسام هي هي هي عاليه
جدا روح معنويه عاليه جدا وبالتالي نرى
تنفيذ مثل هذه العمليات على العكس من
الطرف الاخر التي بدات تضغط الحرب النفسيه
عليهم بشكل كبير جدا وبداوا بعمليات ايذاء
النفس وما الى ذلك للخروج من المعركه صحيح
في الوقت الذي تتكيف فيه فصائل المقاومه
كما
ذكرت عقيد الفل لا حي مع معطيات هذه الحرب
الجيش الاسرائيلي وعلى مدى الاسابيع التي
مرت من الحرب لم يتعلم من الميدان لم
يتعلم من تلك الاخطاء وما زال يتكبد
المزيد من الخسائر القناه الثانيه ع
الاسرائيليه تقول ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يستعد لتغيير
خطته لادراك ان حماس لن تهزم دلالات تصريح
واعتراف كهذا و يمكن ان يترتب
عنه نعم لا شك هم يحاولون الان تبرير
الخساره وتبرير عدم قدره هذا الجيش الذي
كان يعد من الجيوش المتقدمه بالقدرات
القتاليه والعسكريه والتكنولوجيه لم يستطع
الى هذه اللحظه ان يحقق اهدافه التي انطلق
من اجلها في هذه العمليه البريه وبالتالي
لابد من مبررات لهذه لهذه الخساره الكبيره
التي تجري الان في ارض الميدان يعني اذا
ما تكلمنا عن تعديل الخطط انا اقول بانه
قد تكون هذه الخطط ليس فيها خلل ولكن
الخلل في المقاتل الذي ينفذ هذه الخطط
والدليل على هذا عندما تتكرر عمليه
الاخطاء بقتل قوات صديقه الجيش الصهيوني
يقوم بقتل مقاتليه في مناطق متعدده وباكثر
من حادثه خلال هذه الفتره هذا ينم عن
ارتباك كبير جدا وعن عدم وجود تنسيق ما
بين القطاعات يضاف الى ذلك بانه يبين
الحاله النفسيه الهستيريه التي توصل اليها
الجندي خلال هذه الفتره لذلك نرى الان
بدات الصحف تتكلم عن لقاءات مع بعض
المقاتلين من اللواء جولاني يتكلمون عن عن
اشكالات نفسيه كبيره جدا ادت الى ايذاء
النفس واستخدام المخدرات والمشروبات لكي
يتمكنوا من الهروب من ساحه المعركه لذلك
نرى بان عمليه سحب هذه القطعات وتبديلها
بقطعات اخرى يضاف الى ذلك محاوله تعديل
الخطط كل هذا لن ياتي بشيء جديد في ارض
المعركه لن يستطيعوا ان يغيروا نفسيه
الجندي المقاتل بالنسبه للجيش خلال هذه
الفتره ولا يمكن له ان يدربو على القتال
في المناطق المبنيه لان في الحرب لا يمكن
لك ان تتدرب في الحرب هذه المعركه الان
معارك ضاريه وشرسه وعنيفه ولا يمكن للان
ان يحاولوا ان يقوموا بتعديل مسار المعركه
من خلال هذه الاجراءات التي يقومون بها هم
يستخدمون القوى التدميريه نعم هذه القوى
واضحه العيان قتل مدنيين تدمير بنى تحتيه
تدمير المباني ولكنهم لا يواجهون قوه
كامله في منطقه معينه لانه تكيفت حماس
وبقيه الفصائل مع طبيعه هذه المعركه لذلك
هم يتنقلون في مناطق متعدده ويحاولون ان
لا يواجهوا العدو مواجهه مباشره عندما
تكون عندما يكون المهاجم في ذروه
هجومه ويحاولون امتصاص زخم الهجمات ثم بعد
ذلك تبدا هذه العمليات والدليل على هذا
بان العمليات عادت الى مناطق تم التوغل
اليها منذ فتره طويله من الاجتياح البري
عادت اليها العمليات مره اخرى خلال هذه
الفتره شكرا جزيلا لك العقيد الركن حاتم
كريم الفلاحي الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
كنت معنا من اسطنبول